[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie wir bereits in einem früheren video
berichtet haben versucht russland seit
jahren seine abhängigkeit von den
westlichen volkswirtschaften zu
verringern zu diesem zweck hat es
versucht seine finanzielle einigkeit vom
ausland reduzieren kurse devisenreserven
angehäuft und eine politik der import
substitution verfolgt nun hat sich
jedoch gezeigt dass die ergebnisse
dieser festung russland strategie soll
ich sagen nicht gerade atemberaubend
waren russland wurde geradezu kalt
erwischt ein großteil der
devisenreserven wurden vom westen
eingefroren und die russische wirtschaft
ist noch immer sehr stark von
lieferungen aus dem ausland abhängig vor
allem wenn es um hochtechnologie geht
die internationalen sanktionen treffen
die russische wirtschaft immer härter
die besten schätzungen die ich momentan
eher deuten darauf hin dass die
russische wirtschaft auf die hälfte
ihrer größe vor der invasion reduziert
wird der stellvertretende nationale
sicherheitsberater der usa um euch eine
vorstellung vom außen aus der misere zu
geben im jahr 2021 gaben etwa 80 prozent
aller unternehmen der russischen
verarbeitenden industrie an dass sie auf
komponenten aus dem ausland angewiesen
sein dies ist zum beispiel beim
lkw-hersteller kamaz der fall der gerade
einen produktionsrückgang von 40 prozent
aufgrund fehlender komponenten ein grund
hat nach angaben des unternehmens sind
15.000 arbeitsplätze in gefahr
[Musik]
moskaus bürgermeister sieht gar 200.000
arbeitsplätze gefährdet und laut einer
studie der wirtschaftshochschule moskau
wurden im jahr 2020 fast 75 prozent
aller in russland verbrauchten und
konsumgüter aus dem ausland importiert
jetzt wodurch die sanktionen die
internationalen märkte für russland zu
einem großen teil dicht sind kommt ein
schwerer schlag nach dem anderen für
seine ohnehin schon auch vorher
angeschlagene wirtschaft das hat sogar
wladimir putin selbst eingeräumt unsere
wirtschaft in diesen neuen realitäten
tiefgreifende strukturelle veränderungen
brauchen und ich will nicht verhehlen
dass sie nicht einfach sein werden
wladimir putin präsident russlands und
ihr könnt euch schon selbst eine
vorstellung davon machen wie schlimm die
lage wirklich sein muss wenn putin
selbst schon vor schwierigkeiten in
einem land spricht in dem offiziell
immer alles wundert richtig läuft dank
der unendlichen weisheit seines
unzählbaren führers tja und nun richten
sich alle augen auf china
wird der asiatische riese die russische
wirtschaft retten inwieweit kann moskau
auf die unterstützung pekings zählen das
alles wollen wir diesem video genau
unter die lupe nehmen lasst uns also
gleich loslegen
[Musik]
friede freude eierkuchen
es handelt sich um kein großes geheimnis
in den letzten jahren haben putins
russland und china ihre beziehungen
sowohl politisch als auch wirtschaftlich
stark ausgebaut der asiatische riese ist
mit abstand der größte handelspartner
russlands fast ein viertel aller waren
die russland einkauf von kleidung bis
ins fernsehen kommt aus der
volksrepublik china
und es geht nicht nur um handel russland
ist auch zu einem führenden kreditmarkt
für chinesische finanzinstitute geworden
zwischen den jahren 2000 2017
verschuldete sich der russische bär bei
den chinesen mit mehr als 150 millionen
us dollar die zusammenarbeit erstreckt
sich auch auf den militärischen bereich
zum beispiel für und beide länder in
letzter zeit häufig gemeinsame manöver
durch
vielleicht besser erklärten die beiden
staatsoberhäupter bei ihrem treffen in
peking am 14 februar 2022 allerdings
nicht olympischen winterspiele dass die
freundschaft zwischen den beiden mächten
keine grenzen kenne man sprach von einer
freundschaft ohne grenzen
martina zb die beschränkungen für
russische weisen importe aufgehoben und
die beiden länder haben vereinbart ihren
energiehandel zu stärken mit anderen
worten in den nächsten jahren wird china
mehr russisches gas und öl einkaufen als
die alliierten begannen die russische
wirtschaft mit sanktionen zu bestrafen
richteten sich plötzlich alle augen auf
china weil die beziehungen zwischen
peking und moskau immer enger werden und
das pseudo kommunistische regime die
anwendung von wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen russland entschieden abgelehnt hat
seit 2011 haben die usa mehr als 100
sanktionen gegen russland verhängt aber
haben die us aktionär irgendein problem
gelöst ist die welt durch die sanktionen
ein besserer ort geworben wird sich das
problem der ukraine dank der
us-sanktionen gegen russland von selbst
lösen wird die sicherheit europas dank
der us-aktion gegen russland
gewährleistet was schon gegen eine
sprecherin des chinesischen
aussenministeriums aber die eigentliche
frage lautet wird china russland
tatsächlich zu hilfe eilen kann china
die auswirkungen der sanktionen auf die
russische wirtschaft wirklich abmelden
werden chinesische unternehmen in
betracht ziehen vermögenswerte und
märkte zu übernehmen die von westlichen
unternehmen aufgegeben werden und passt
auf den es gibt spekulationen dass
einige staatliche giganten wie china
national petroleum corporation die china
petrochemical corporation und china
minmetals corporation bereits darüber
nachdenken sich viele russische
vermögenswerten zu schnäppchenpreisen
einzuverleiben der ausverkauf dessen was
von der russischen wirtschaft noch übrig
geblieben ist ist also bereits im vollen
gange allerdings ist damit die frage ob
china die russische wirtschaft wirklich
retten kann ja überhaupt nicht
beantwortet die wahrheit ist dass es
alles andere als klar ist ob sie es
überhaupt könnten und vor allem ob sie
es überhaupt wollen was genau ich damit
meine nun spitzt euro ohren denn was in
diesem video kommt sonst setzt die
meisten beobachter bei der länder
ziemlich überraschend
[Musik]
kapazitätsprobleme
[Applaus]
die erste frage die wir uns stellen
müssen ist was genau könnte china tun
und die russische wirtschaft zu
unterstützen nun mal sehen wir können da
gleich mehrere ideen auf den tisch legen
die chinesische regierung könnte zb den
handel erleichtern indem sie zölle und
bürokratie abbaut die chinesische
industrie kultur russland mit
komponenten versorgen die es im westen
nicht mehr kaufen kann oder sie könnte
auch ihre großen staatlichen unternehmen
in unternehmen oder projekte in russland
investieren lassen gut dies alles sind
dinge auf jedes kleine kind kommen würde
aber dann wären dann doch ein paar
maßnahmen die im allgemeinen weniger
bekannt sind wie gehen könnte einen teil
der 120 milliarden dollar schulden
welches bei der russischen zentralbank
angehäuft habe vorzeitig begleicht sie
können sogar eine damit bank gründen
über welches in russland helfen würden
einige der sanktionen zu umgehen gut
china könnte all diese dinge tun aber
das problem ist dass das alles sowieso
nicht ausreichen würde
denn auf der einen seite hat russland
eine kleine und unterentwickelte
wirtschaft die hauptsächlich rohstoffe
exportiert so sehr die chinesen auch
bereit wären dinge in russland zu kaufen
die wahrheit ist dass die spielräume
dafür extrem bescheiden sind tatsache
ist nun mal dass russland noch lange
darauf angewiesen sein wird seine
rohstoffe an den westen zu verkaufen
denn die lieferung dieser rohstoffe an
china würde eine infrastruktur
erforderlich machen die es heute noch
nicht gibt und deren aufbau jahre dauern
würde russland hat ist zb versäumt
anlagen zur verflüssigung seines
erdgases aufzubauen so dass es als lng
tanker an beliebige orte transportiert
werden könnte es ist daher fast
vollständig auf die bestehende pipelines
angewiesen und diese führen eben dorthin
wo ist ein rohstoff wird schon zu
sowjetzeiten haus nicht verkauft hat
nach europa und wir sprechen hier nicht
über kinkerlitzchen sondern über einen
fetten kuchen auf der einen und ein paar
krümel auf der anderen seite grübel von
denen niemand wirklich satz werden kann
wo euch mal die proportionen vor augen
zu führen über die wir hier reden im
jahr 2021 importierte china zum beispiel
zehn milliarden kubikmeter gas aus
russland über die neue sibirische
gaspipeline mittlerweile hat russland
ihre jährliche kapazität zwar auf 16 5
milliarden kubikmeter verdreifacht und
die gesamt liter kapazität nach china
mit hilfe einer neuen pipeline bis zum
jahr 2020 nochmals auf 38 milliarden
kubikmeter erhöhen wenn man dies jedoch
mit den liefermengen nach europa in
bezug setzt wird auch das wie ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein denn europa
kauft den russen jährlich sage und
schreibe zwischen 185 und 200 milliarden
kubikmeter erdgas ab dass es mehr als
fünfmal so viel wie die menge die großen
und ab 2025 nach china zu liefern oft
und das nur wenn alles gut geht das
heißt vor allem wenn die chinesen
mitspielt
[Musik]
in peking hat man nämlich ganz genau
beobachtet was in europa die ganze zeit
ablief wie korrupte politiker und
gierige wirtschaftsbosse den ganzen
kontinent und vor allem deutschland
immer mehr vom russischen gas abhängig
gemacht und ihre staaten und
volkswirtschaften damit umsichtige
spielräume beraubt haben um
wirtschaftliche wie politische
spielräume welche vor allem in
krisensituationen wie der jetzigen
wichtig wäre die chinesischen politiker
sind zwar auch korrupt aber mehr von
ihnen als von außen
sie sind keine landesverräter die irland
von einem unberechenbaren potentaten in
moskau wenn ich machen wollen denn sie
haben wahrlich bessere möglichkeiten um
ihre privatkonten zu füllen es ist daher
vollkommen klar dass china auf gar
keinen fall den vorteilen der europäer
wiederholen wird und einem weiteren
ausbau von erdgas pipeline aus russland
grünes licht gibt um das ganze nochmals
ins verhältnis zu setzen allein durch
nord stream zwei sollten 55 milliarden
kubikmeter pro jahr fließen also 45
prozent mehr als die für 2025 angestrebt
abnahmemenge chinas beim thema erdgas
wird china russland also nicht wirklich
helfen können und auch nicht wollen
wie gesagt ein austausch europas gegen
china wäre für russland wie der tausch
eines riesigen kuchens gegen ein paar
krümel gut aber was ist mit den apple
nun auch da sieht es verdammt maus auch
hier versucht china nämlich seine
lieferanten zu diversifizieren und preis
nicht gegeneinander auszuspielen darüber
hinaus sinken die ölimporte chinas
aufgrund verschiedener faktoren die
korona lockte aus der globalisierung und
auch der stockenden bevölkerung so das
ding hier sowieso kaum spielräume für
mehr einkäufer hat und auch hier bleiben
den russen allein aus kapazitätsgründen
diesmal nicht wegen dem zylinder
transportmöglichkeit sondern aufgrund
fehlender nachfrage nur ein paar krümel
vom großen kuchen übrig außerdem kommen
sich china und saudi arabien immer näher
und schmieden einen plan um ihren
erdmantel in zukunft nicht mehr in
dollar sondern yuan abzuwickeln ob und
inwieweit der dollar als leitwährung
durch den krieg droht ist dann muss
übrigens bald in einem separaten video
ansehen vergesst also bringt das abo und
das glöckchen um keines unserer videos
zu verpassen fakt ist dass selbst im
ersten quartal 2022 saudi in russland
als chinas öllieferant nummer eins
abgelöst hat und das obwohl die russen
aufgrund der sanktionen außerordentliche
rabatte angeboten haben dies hat vor
allem damit zu tun dass die russen ihr
bild öl in china vor allem an klein und
unabhängige raffinerie liefern welche
jedoch startet umweltverschmutzer sind
gegen diese dreckigen raffinerien geht
die regierung in peking aber aus
umweltschutzgründen stark vor und
vergibt importlizenzen nur noch an neue
und moderne raffineriebetreiber diese
sind jedoch meist durch langfristige
lieferverträge an saudi arabien gebunden
und haben überhaupt kein interesse ihre
langjährigen partner vor den kopf zu
stoßen nur um das russische sauerbier öl
abzunehmen
[Musik]
und also mit dem öl wird auch nichts
wenn ich ihn an den russen also als
käufer von rohstoffen nicht wirklich
unter die arme greifen kann wird es sich
wenigstens als verkäufer nützlich machen
können und die epos ausfälle aus dem
westen abfedern vor allem das
fortschrittliche produkte angeht welche
in den herstellungs- und lieferketten
der russischen wirtschaft jetzt so
schmerzhaft fehlen nun auch hierbei
sieht es verdammt düster aus und zwar
aus drei gründen erstens auch weil viele
dinge in china hergestellt werden heißt
es nicht dass sie nach russland verkauft
werden können produkte die von
westlichen unternehmen in china
hergestellt wurden können nicht nach
russland verkauft werden zweitens sind
auch zahlreiche chinesische unternehmen
entweder technologisch nicht so weit
fortgeschritten oder auf lieferungen und
zugang zu technologie aus dem westen
angewiesen und hierzu müssen wir nicht
nur die usa europa sondern auch japan
taiwan und südkorea peking denkt auch
hier in erster linie an sich und wird
auf gar keinen fall den zugang seiner
unternehmen zu schlüsseltechnologien und
komponenten gefährden was jedoch der
fall sein könnte wenn ihre fertigen
produkte in russland landen würden wir
sprechen jetzt nicht über handys hier
ist es in amerikanern und wollen ihren
geheimdienst nur recht wenn die russen
weiterhin massenhaft android und ios
geräte nutzen und ihr wisst genau was
ich meine aber schauen wir uns doch mal
das beispiel der luftfahrtindustrie
anfangen
[Musik]
flugzeuge sind wird das geografisch
größte land der welt nämlich ein enorm
wichtiges produkt nicht nur für die
wirtschaft im land sondern auch um die
weit abgelegenen regionen überhaupt von
moskau aus regieren zu können ein schlag
gegen die luftfahrt in russland stellt
also eine direkte gefahr für den
zusammenhalt und die existenzfähigkeit
des russischen staates da und
internationale sanktionen verbieten ist
nun westlichen unternehmen wie airbus
oder boeing flugzeuge komponenten teile
triebwerke oder dienstleistungen
jeglicher art nach russland zu verkaufen
dinge die offensichtlich benötigt werden
damit flugzeuge überhaupt fliegen können
gut nun könnte man auf den ersten blick
meinen dass die russischen
luftfahrtindustrie die inklusive
militärischer hersteller über 100
unternehmens zählt doch mächtig genug
sein sollte um das eigene land mit
ausreichend flugzeugen und ersatzteil zu
versorgen vor allem wenn man die große
tradition der sowjetischen luftfahrt in
betracht zieht doch gerade zu
sowjetzeiten waren die hersteller vieler
kritischer flugzeugkomponenten nicht in
russland angesiedelt sondern in der
ukraine und um mit dem tempo des
globalen wettbewerb mithalten zu können
und logisch nicht noch weiter
zurückzufallen hat ein russischer
hersteller die tupolew oder ihre keine
andere wahl als auf viele kritische
komponenten aus dem westen
zurückzugreifen da diese nun fehlen
stehen ihre fabriken erstmal still
selbst die um optimistische pläne nie
verlegene russische regierung rechnet
nun damit dass sich zum beispiel die
serienproduktion gut im c 21 und bis zu
zwei jahre verzögern wird die
ausländischen komponenten sind dabei
nicht nur wichtig um faktoren wie die
kompatibilität zu internationalen
standards und normen zu gewährleisten
sondern auch um bei punkten die
treibstoffeffizienz navigation
wartbarkeit sicherheit und langlebigkeit
nicht um 50 jahre zurück zu fallen mal
ganz davon zu schweigen dass ist in
russland gar nicht das know how dafür
gibt know how an dessen aufbau selbst
china trotz jahrzehntelanger
anstrengungen gescheitert ist denn auch
china stellt diese teile entweder nicht
her oder hat bereits klar gemacht dass
sie nicht an russland verkaufen wird
schon allein weil es erst benötigt oder
weil es die eigene luftfahrt nicht durch
westliche technologie sanktionen
gefährden will
und damit wären wir auch schon beim
dritten grund warum china russland
technologisch nicht aus der patsche
helfen wird viele chinesische
unternehmen haben ganz einfach angst vor
dem reputationsrisiko das ihnen auf
vielen lukrativen märkten schaden könnte
und auch davor dass am ende des sekundär
sanktionen beschlossen werden könnten
sie wissen dass wenn sie den bogen
überspannen und russland beim umgehen
der sanktionen helfen würden in viel
größerer schaden droht nämlich
sanktionen gegen alle unternehmen die
überhaupt in russland tätig sind
[Musik]
und hier kommt eine weitere kuchen und
krümel analogie zum tragen nur würden
hierbei chinesische firmen den
westlichen kuchen gegen ein paar
russische krümmel tauschen und damit
ihre konkurrenzfähigkeit auf dem
globalen markt aufs spiel setzen etwas
wozu sie auf gar keinen fall bereit sind
das hat unternehmen wie volvo oder tik
tok die sich in diese schule besitz
befinden dazu veranlasst selbst
diejenigen geschäft in russland auch zu
wissen die nicht von den sanktionen
betroffen waren und ich weiß dass dieses
ziel nicht mitbekommen haben und die
meisten sogar glauben chinesische
unternehmen würde sich es nur so auf den
russischen markt stürzen um die
entstandenen lücken zu schließen in
wahrheit sind sie jedoch extrem
zurückhaltend selbst chinesische
staatsunternehmen denn genau die
genannten gründe erklären warum sich
ausgerechnet zwei der big four der
chinesische staatsbanken die bank of
china und die industrial and commercial
bank of china ihre geschäfte mit
russlands sofort nach beginn der
invasion eingeschränkt haben das gleiche
hat auch die asiatische infrastruktur
investitionsbank im grunde die
chinesische weltbank getan indem sie die
kreditvergabe an russland und
weißrussland eingestellt hat china
versucht russland auf distanz zu halten
sie wollen sich nicht exponieren indem
sie die internationalen sanktionen
umgehen man hat der ems analyse bei
monex europe was die investitionen in
russland angeht so ist es war möglich es
einige chinesische staatsunternehmen
vermögenswerte im ausland zu sehr
günstigen preisen kaufen werden aber das
nur sehr vorsichtig die angst vor
sanktionen deshalb das risiko und die
tatsache dass der russische markt sehr
klein ist sind alles dinge die den
großen kaufrausch verhindern
[Musik]
sie werden sich nur dann engagieren wenn
es für sie wirklich extrem günstig ist
so dass all diese risiken kompensiert
werden dies ist natürlich extrem
ungünstig für russland und damit alles
andere als eine hilfe der einzige den
china also helfen wird ist china selbst
und es wird dabei 0 rücksicht auf ein
abstoßendes land wie russland nehmen
schauen wir uns das beispiel chemie an
dass 40 prozent des russischen handy
marktes beherrscht ja das unternehmen
kann sicherlich vom ausstieg von
unternehmen wie apple profitieren aber
es wird kaum das risiko eingehen große
investitionen in einen ganztägigen das
kommt 3 prozent seines weltweiten
umsatzes ausmacht china wird das
sinkende schiff der russischen
wirtschaft nicht treffen vielleicht
lässt ist das schiff ein wenig länger
treiben und langsamer sinken es war trat
wirtschaftswissenschaftler an der
cornell university das heißt selbst wenn
die regierung von shopping russland
wirklich helfen wollte verfügt sie
einfach nicht über die kapazitäten dies
ausreichendem umfang zu tun schon allein
aus dem grund weil chinesen dabei nicht
selbst auf der strecke bleiben wollen
[Musik]
china hat selbst mit genug eigene
probleme zu kämpfen über die wir im
vergangenen videos schon viel berichtet
haben eine ragt dabei jedoch heraus
selbst wissenschaftler welche offiziell
für die regierung in peking arbeiten
bestätigen nun dass chinas bevölkerung
bereits in diesem jahr schrumpfen wird
und dies ist eine regelrechte bombay
welt in den nachrichten jedoch
vollkommen untergegangen ist und ihr
fragt euch warum es sich um eine so
große bombe handelt es geht hier um ein
ganzes jahrzehnt in welchem ich immer
gehofft hatte den wohlstand zu rückstand
zum besten zu schließen die einzige
chance des riesenlandes eine kommende
rentner labile noch irgendwie wirklich
auffangen zu können doch nun scheint ist
zu später für die zahl der menschen die
65 jahre und älter sind wird im jahr
2021 als 14 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung ausmachen was china zu
einer gealterten und nicht mehr zu einer
alternden gesellschaft macht alle
früheren prognosen sind nun hinfällig
und eine negative auswirkung der
überalterung ist die verlangsamung des
wirtschaftswachstums die überalterung
wird zu einem rückgang der brutto
ersparnis der chinesischen haushalte im
vergleich zu ihrer verfügbaren einkommen
führen und ihre schulden werden weiter
steigen dieses fehlende geld wird dann
wiederum zu einem rückgang der
investitionen führen was in china ein
großes problem darstellen wird und es
wird natürlich jenes geld fehlen um die
rentner welle abzufangen denn der
typische chinesische arbeitnehmer trifft
kaum vorsorge fürs alter das reich der
mitte ist auf dem besten wege bis 2035
zu einer super alten gesellschaft zu
werden in der mehr als 20 prozent der
bevölkerung über 60 jahre alt sind das
verhältnis von rentnern zu arbeitnehmern
im jahr 2030 auf 25 prozent steigen und
je mehr 2050 voraussichtlich 43 prozent
übersteigen die fatale 0 kurve strategie
der regierung wird den niedrigen
geburten und heiraten noch auf jahre hin
weiter verschärfen viele junge menschen
haben keine möglichkeit sich überhaupt
kennen zu lernen und frauen haben
aufgrund der brutalen loch baumaßnahmen
angst schwanger zu werden müsst ihr wann
das letzte mal die geburtenrate in china
so niedrig war wie heute in den 1960 er
jahren als der großen hungersnot über 50
millionen chinesen zum opfer fielen aber
die wahrheit mine liegen zuschauer ist
dass china nicht nur ganz andere sorgen
hat um sich ein
die versenkung abschlüssen des russland
zu kümmern die wahrheit ist dass die
russland gar nicht retten wollen was ich
damit meine nun aufgepasst denn jetzt
wird erst so richtig spannend
[Musik]
bitte nicht noch mehr probleme
wie gesagt läuft die chinesische
wirtschaft nicht gerade auf hochtouren
für das jahr 2022 wird ein wachstum von
5,5 prozent erwartet das ist die
niedrigste seit 1991 und es ist
keineswegs sicher dass sie selbst diese
erreichen werden china hat derzeit mit
einer immobilienkrise einer potenziell
finanzkrise den folgenden staatliche
eingriffe in den technologie-sektor der
konkurrenz durch neue produktions märkte
wie vietnam einem kongress der shopping
wieder wählen muss einer demografischen
krise und zu allem überfluss auch noch
mit der selbstverschuldeten 0-coup
sackgasse zu kämpfen ja in china werden
die menschen immer noch in ihren häusern
eingesperrt der druck in der 25
millionenstadt shanghai steigt da die
crew mit 19 lockt bei uns weiterhin in
kraft bleiben es ist einfach verrückt
aber über die politischen gründe haben
wir in einem früheren video gesprochen
dass ich euch verlinken werde nun kurz
gesagt china hat momentan nicht gerade
viele erfolge zu feiern und man merkt
die bedrückende stimmung überall im land
eine gesellschaftlich vor kurzem noch an
den über turbo erfolgs modus gewöhnt war
stellt immer mehr fest dass ihre
zukunftsperspektiven immer weiter
schwinden die regierung verfügt daher
nur über sehr wenig spielraum
welche sanktionen und probleme aller art
zu riskieren nur um eine so unbedeutende
wirtschaft wie die russische zu stützen
[Musik]
während das kapital in die meisten
schwellenländer fließt fließt ist aus
china ab was die krise dort noch
verschärfen könnte es geht nicht nur
darum dass ich je nach für viele
investoren nicht mehr lohnt weil es
irgendwo mittlerweile günstigere
wirtschaftliche bedingungen gibt nein es
geht darum dass die russische invasion
der ukraine die wahrnehmung vieler
investoren vollkommen verändert hat sie
vertrauen china nicht mehr so wie früher
moskau zieht peking mit in den abgrund
dieser kapitalabfluss könnte durch
zinserhöhungen der us-notenbank noch
weiter verschärft werden denn wenn ein
land wie die usa die zinsen anhebt
investieren anleger liebe in us-anleihen
als in die schulden risikoreichere
länder da sich der renditeabstand zu den
schwellenländern verringert und das
könnte einen großen teil dieser
investitionen gefährden ausländische
beständig chinesische anleihen steigen
im dezember 2021 500 milliarden us
dollar das ist ein anstieg um fast 50%
gegenüber 2020 das ist aber noch nicht
alles zu allem überfluss hat der krieg
in der ukraine das vor beigetragen dass
die preise für energie rohstoffe und
lebensmittel gestiegen sind ein thema
das für china hochgradig kritisch ist
wenn seine wirtschaft ist wie wir in
einem früheren video erklärt haben sehr
ineffizient china hat eine wirtschaft
die jetzt mehr denn je ausländische
investitionen und internationale märkte
für ihre exporte benötigt und mit dir
was aus diesem grund sind die usa und
die eu für china viel viel viel
wichtiger als russland sie sind
überlebenswichtig ihr glaubt mir nicht
dann hört euch einfach mal die folgenden
zahlen an
im jahr 2021 belegt sich der handel
zwischen china und russland auch etwa
147 milliarden dollar mit den
vereinigten staaten sind es über 825
milliarden dollar und mit der
europäischen union
750 milliarden dollar damit ihr euch ein
bild machen könnt der handel mit den usa
und der eu was 2001 man sich fast elf
mal größer als der handel mit russland
und wenn der weitere verbündete länder
wie japan taiwan südkorea und australien
zu rechnen wächst dieses verhältnis auf
sagenhafte 25 zu 1 dieses krasse
verhältnis betrifft nicht nur den handel
wieder mal kuchen gegen krümmel nein
noch krasser wird es bei den
investitions strömen hier kann man noch
nicht mal mehr von krümeln sprechen um
es also noch mal zusammenzufassen
china hat große probleme china braucht
die märkte und internationale investoren
um überhaupt eine chance zu haben seine
demografische katastrophe irgendwie
abzufedern und russland spielt in der
weltwirtschaft eine eher untergeordnete
rolle noch nicht einmal bei den
rohstoffen kann es china wirklich helfen
china muss also vor allem pragmatisch
handeln russland ist ein im niedergang
begriffen macht daher china keinen grund
russland aus der patsche zu helfen denn
china selbst wirtschaftlich viel stärker
mit der eu und den usa verflochten ist
also auch wenn es peking könnte wäre es
einfach nur wahnsinn russland zu helfen
aber achtung wir sind noch lange nicht
fertig
[Musik]
chance oder brandbeschleuniger
china entwickelt sich die russische
invasion in der ukraine allmählich zu
einem immer größeren und mittlerweile
riesigen albtraum die energiekosten sind
in die höhe geschnellt die angst der
investoren hat zugenommen und der krieg
verlangsamen den eisenbahnverkehr der
china über russland mit europa verbindet
und eigentlich ein wichtiger bestandteil
der neuen seidenstraße sein sollte und
zu allem überfluss kündigen chinas
nachbarn jetzt rekord steigerungen in
ihren militärbudgets an über das alles
ist peking natürlich nicht besonders
erfreut denn so habe der ehemalige
premierminister japans sich sogar dafür
ausgesprochen dass die vereinigten
staaten atomwaffen im land der
aufgehenden sonne stationieren dürfen ja
ihr habt euch nicht verhört das einzige
land der welt gegen das atomwaffen
jemals eingesetzt wurden und dass
deswegen ein gigantisches trauma
erlitten hat bettelt nun darum dass die
usa dort atomwaffen stationiert der
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine und die dauernden atom drohungen
putins haben also nicht nur die nato
wieder enger zusammengeschweißt sondern
weltweit allen ländern die nicht in der
nato sind oder sessel atomwaffen
verfügen gezeigt dass sie in jener neuen
weltordnung die putin und sie anstreben
zu freiwild geworden sind ihre angst
davor china könnte zu ähnlichen mitteln
wie russland greifen ist in
unermessliche höhen geschnellt und hat
sie im turbogang in die arme der usa
getrieben aber wartet noch ein bisschen
nensel peking hat das ganze vielleicht
auch etwas gutes schaut euch mal an
shipping vor der joe biden auf sich
gemeinsam für den frieden einzusetzen
krieg nützt niemandem genau china kann
jetzt seine neutralität nutzen um mit
den vereinigten staaten im gegenzug für
bestimmte vorteile zu verhandeln es gibt
zum beispiel um die aufhebung eines
teils der von trump beschlossenen zelle
[Musik]
tatsächlich hielten krise joe biden am
18 märz 2022 ein telefon gipfel ab der
den beiderseitigen tod durchaus
verbesserte und als geste des guten
willens hat die beiden regierungen
gerade zölle auf 3 unter 52 chinesische
produkte auch geschafft und an us börsen
notierte chinesische unternehmen konnten
in der hoffnung auf eine normalisierung
der beziehungen zwischen beiden ländern
wieder boden gutmachen gegen den
verzicht auf die hilfe für russland also
als währung um sich mehr spielraum für
andere ambitionen zu erkaufen worum es
dabei geht und in erster linie darum das
chinesische unternehmen in russland erst
mal vermögenswerte zu schnäppchen
preisen kaufen können aber auch das ist
nur der erste schritt einer viel
weitreichendere und langfristigen
strategie durch den zerfall der
russischen armee und luftfahrt wirkt
ostsibirien aber auch die
ressourcenreiche arktisregion in den
augen chinesischer militärplaner immer
mehr wie ein großes stück und besetzten
landes die bulls krieger haben bereits
anspruch auf wladiwostok erhoben auch
mit dem verweis auf historische besitz
bespreche chinas schließlich gehörte
wladiwostok wie auch die ganze äußere
manche reist zur chinesischen team denn
dusty und hieß früher bei shell wie das
russische reich annektierte die region
im jahr 1860 während der schwächephase
chinas nach der niederlage gegen die
briten und franzosen im zweiten
opiumkrieg diese schmach sind genießen
noch immer ziemlich tief in den knochen
deswegen in den chinesischen medien
immer wieder revanchistische fantasien
kursieren man hätte doch jetzt in einer
schwächephase auslass das recht den
spieß umzudrehen und sich das
zurückzuholen was der star dem kaiser
ist gestohlen hat jetzt wird zunächst
die wirtschaftliche präsenz ausgebaut
welche er meist auch mit dem zuzug die
chinesen verbunden ist aber für die zeit
danach wenn ausreichend fakten
geschaffen sind ist das rhetorische und
ideologische rüstzeug schon mal
vorhanden daher wird china
höchstwahrscheinlich noch nicht einmal
versuchen die russische wirtschaft zu
retten es hätte absolut nichts davon im
gegenteil was also bleibt russland übrig
wie sie tut dies aktueller plan aus dem
partner sanktionen trotzdem stand zu
halten jetzt wo sich viele seine
vermeintlichen trümpfe in luft aufgelöst
haben genau dies werden wir uns einem
der nächsten videos hier genauer ansehen
aber jetzt seid ihr erstmal mit eurer
meinung an der reihe denkt ihr dass
china noch versuchen wird für nicht
verdeckt russland zu unterstützen welche
risiken geht es dabei ein und wie sollte
der westen darauf reagieren was würdet
ihr tun daneben schießhaus stecken würde
wie soll sie sich ihrer ansicht nach
china verhalten wie immer sind auf eure
kommentare schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat und
die verwaltung etwas arbeit gelernt habe
sagt uns mit allen leichter als mit
einem freund und vergiss nicht mit
glöckchen um keines unseren videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine spende von euch
mädels hälfte dieses projekt
weiterzuführen denn paper link dazu
findet ihr wie immer in der beschreibung
unter dem video mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]